foreign
you're sitting on the couch watching TV
when you hear a knock on the door the
police have just arrived to arrest your
spouse for murder this accusation comes
as a total shock
wow in your experience your partner has
always been gentle and loving and you
can't imagine them committing a grisly
murder but the evidence is serious their
fingerprints were found on the murder
weapon your spouse insists they're
innocent I know it looks bad they say
but you have to believe me if you don't
who will
should you believe your spouse even
though the evidence against them looks
damning take a second to think what you
would believe in this situation
this dilemma is part of what
philosophers call the ethics of belief a
field of study that explores how we
ought to form beliefs and whether we
have ethical duties to believe certain
things
the question here isn't about what you
should do such as whether or not you
should find your spouse guilty in a
court of law after all you wouldn't be
on the jury in their trial rather it's
about what you should believe to be true
so what factors should you consider
perhaps the most obvious is your
evidence after all to believe something
is to take it to be true and evidence is
by definition all information that helps
us determine what's true from this some
philosophers draw the conclusion that
evidence is the only thing that ought to
determine what you believe this view is
called evidentialism and a strict
evidentialist would say it doesn't
matter that the accused is your spouse
you should evaluate the evidence from a
neutral objective point of view taking
the perspective of an unbiased third
party your judgment of your spouse's
character is a relevant consideration
but finding their fingerprints at the
crime scene is sure really stronger
evidence so from an evidentialist point
of view you should either believe your
spouse is guilty or at best remain
undecided
some philosophers present evidentialism
only as a view of what's most rational
to believe but others like 19th century
evidentialist w k Clifford think that
following the evidence is also morally
required one argument for this view is
that having well-informed accurate
beliefs is often vitally important to
determining the ethical way to act
another argument is that there's
something unethical about being
dishonest and refusing to follow the
evidence is a way of being dishonest
with oneself however perhaps there are
other ethical factors in play
although the evidence against your
spouse is strong there's still a chance
that they're actually innocent think for
a moment about how it would feel to be
innocent and have no one believe you not
even your own partner by not trusting
your spouse you run the risk of
seriously hurting them in their crucial
hour of need
moreover consider what this lack of
trust would do to your marriage it would
be incredibly difficult to continue a
loving relationship with someone that
you believed or even strongly suspected
was a murderer you might try to pretend
to believe that your spouse is Innocent
but could you really go on living that
lie according to a theory of the ethics
of belief called pragmatism these kinds
of practical considerations can
sometimes make it right to believe
something even without strong evidence
some pragmatists would even say that you
morally owe it to your spouse to believe
them
but is it even possible to believe your
spouse is innocent just because you
think it'll be good for your
relationship or because you think you
owe it to the accused you might
desperately want to believe they're
Innocent but can you control your
beliefs in the same way you control your
actions it seems like you can't just
believe whatever you like when the truth
is staring you in the face but on the
other hand recall your spouse's plea
when we say things like this we seem to
be assuming that it is possible to
control our beliefs in some way
so what do you think can you control
what beliefs you have and if so what
will you believe about your spouse okay
here's another one if everyone agrees on
something it must be true right not so
fast sometimes the closer we get to
unanimity the more skeptical we should
be learn more with this video or learn
about the ethical dilemma of
self-driving cars